>> Tucker: LET’S SEE THE
APPLICATIONS.
>> I’M HAPPY FOR THAT
UNFORTUNATELY LIVE I DON’T
CONTROL IT.
>> Tucker: I DON’T EITHER.
FLEET, THANK YOU.
>> NO, THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: KIM STRASSEL IS
ON THE EDITORIAL BOARD.
I WANTS YOUR REACTION SINCE
YOU COVER THIS.
WE LEARNED IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" PIECE 50 MINUTES AGO
THAT U.S. INTEL AGENCIES
UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PAID 100
GRAND TO GET SALACIOUS
INFORMATION AND APPARENTLY
FALSE INFORMATION ON TRUMP.
DOES THAT SOUND KIND OF JUST
LIKE NORMAL BUSINESS AS
USUAL TO YOU?
>> NO.
IT DOES NOT.
BECAUSE AS WAS JUST NOTED,
ONE THING TO GO OUT AND
SPEND MONEY POTENTIALLY
GETTING INFORMATION ON A
SWORN ENEMY OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IT’S ANOTHER TO GO OUT AND
SPEND $100,000 TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION ON THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
>> Tucker: YEAH, I MEAN
PRESUMABLY, ACCORDING TO THE
"TIMES" PIECE IT WASN’T
INFORMATION SUGGESTED HE WAS
SELLING SECRETS TO ANYBODY.
IT WAS INFORMATION OF A
SEXUAL NATURE PROBABLY NOT
EVEN TRUE.
LIKE IT’S ALSO IRRELEVANT.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, DO YOU
FIND IT STRIKING THAT THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO A YEAR AGO
SAID ANYONE WHO CLAIMS TRUMP
WAS SPIED ON BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION NUT CASE.
THOSE SAME PEOPLE ARE NOW
TELLING US YEAH, OF COURSE,
IT’S TOTALLY NORMAL FOR ONE
ADMINISTRATION TO SPY ON A
RIVAL PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
LIKE NO BIG DEAL.
>> THIS IS THE STORY OF THIS
ENTIRE INVESTIGATION,
TUCKER.
FIRST WE ARE TOLD THAT THE
DOSSIER REPUBLICAN FUNDER.
TURNS OUT IT WAS REPUBLICAN
CAMPAIGN AND DNC.
THEN WE ARE TOLD COULDN’T
POSSIBLY BE USED AS PART OF
A FISA WARRANT.
TURNS OUT IT WAS.
THEN WE ARE TOLD IT MADE BIG
PART OF IT.
IT TURNS OUT IT WAS THE MAIN
PIECE.
NOW WE ARE TOLD IT DOESN’T
REALLY MATTER BECAUSE IT
WASN’T REALLY SPYING ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS SPYING ON A MAN WHO
ALREADY LEFT THE CAMPAIGN,
ONLY THAT’S NOT TRUE EITHER.
IT TURNS OUT IT WAS USED TO
END UP FOLLOWING THE
CONVERSATIONS OF CARTER PAGE
IN WHOEVER ELSE HE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN TALKING TO.
STEVE BANNON WHO HAS BEEN
MENTIONED IS POTENTIALLY
ONLY ONE.
THERE COULD BE MANY OTHER
PEOPLE THAT THEY MANAGED TO
CAPTURE BECAUSE OF THIS.
>> Tucker: SO HOW CAN -- I
MEAN, IT SEEMS TO ME IT’S
CRITICAL IN ORDER TO RESTORE
FAITH IN GOVERNMENT THAT WE
KNOW THE DETAILS HERE OR
ELSE, YOU KNOW, IN A VACUUM
CREATED BY IGNORANCE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES GROW.
SO HOW DO WE GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, LOOK, FOR
INSTANCE, AT WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN SENATOR GRASSLEY PUT
OUT A LESS REDACTED VERSION
OF HIS REFERRAL LETTER OF A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION OF
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
YOU KNOW, WE WERE TOLD NONE
OF THAT COULD COME OUT, IT
WOULD DAMAGE SOURCES,
METHODS, HIGHLY CLASSIFIED.
YOU LOOK AT IT AND YOU FIND
OUT THAT THE ONLY THING THAT
WAS, IN FACT, WE AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACTED WAS
INFORMATION THAT WAS HIGHLY
SCANDALOUS AND HURTFUL TO
THE FBI THAT UNDERMINED IT
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SO MY QUESTION IS WHY
SHOULDN’T WE PUT OUT THESE
FISA APPLICATIONS?
LET’S PUT OUT ALL THE
DOCUMENTS AND SEE WHERE THE
SKELETONS ARE AND WE CAN BE
CAREFUL OF SOURCES AND
METHODS.
THIS HAS NOW BECOME A FORCE
OF HE SAID, SHE SAID.
AMERICAN PUBLIC DESERVES TO
SEE IT AND JUDGE IT WITH
THEIR OWN EYES.
>> Tucker: YEAH, THE
EMBARRASSMENT OF FEDERAL
BUREAUCRATS IS NOT
JUSTIFICATION FOR KEEPING
SOMETHING SECRET.
IT DOESN’T BELONG TO THEM.
THEY DON’T OPEN THESE
DOCUMENTS.
THEY BELONG TO US.